[Music]
if it already wasn't tough enough for
the living to emerge victorious in the
great war against night king and his
army that it has just become quite a bit
tougher as a flayed knight King has his
own dragon and since dragons are huge
game changers in battlefield the living
will have to figure out a way of killing
the undead this area dragons are
powerful extremely difficult to kill
their scales and heights are incredibly
tough and round when grown they resist
arrows swords and fire Vizier has been
erected into a white Walker which grants
him even more protection the eyes are
where Jagan is most vulnerable the eyes
and the brain behind him in the novel's
Tyrion says that dragon cannot be killed
through the underbelly since scales they
are just as tough as those along dragons
back and flanks then the gullet is not
an option as well to explain all the
possible ways of is Aaron's death which
will surely occur at some point of the
final season let's take a look at how
dragons have been taken down throughout
the history of Westeros the most of the
Targaryen dragons were killed in the
dance of dragons which took place
roughly 107 years before the events of
Game of Thrones it was a civil war
between the Targaryen fighting for the
Iron Throne
the most common way the Dragons have
died is at the claws and the teeth of
either dragons there were 20 dragons
alive at the beginning of the Civil War
and only three survived surely after the
Civil War the Jencks went extinct it was
the only major war that had dragons
fighting on both sides and we have me
now again with two dragons fighting for
the living and one for the dead bazarian
the 19th dragon and the smallest of the
three dragons will have to face his
larger and stronger siblings in the
final season this is not coming as a
huge surprise however as ever since
nothing resurrected vissarion it became
quite certain that the final season will
contain some epic fights between the
dragons many fans seem to like a theory
with dragon kills bazarian which could
have been for share of the in a very
first season vicereine is named after
deniers his brother Viserys and joggin
on the other hand is named after Dana's
late husband Kyle jock back in the first
season wizards threatened a knee which
resulted it Drago killing him by dumping
molten gold onto his head it's quite a
popular theory that Drago named that
reserves will get his own version of the
golden crown in the last season by the
dragon named after Khal Drogo Joe and
killing Azarian would be poetic but
vissarion's not a white sand there for
fire cannot kill him according to the
showrunner Susan is a nice dragon
not just to reanimated corpse and thus
cannot be destroyed by fire let me
explain in season 7 Missourians killed
and then raised back to life by the
night king this led to an online debate
among the fans about what exactly and
that veteran is some claimed him don't
simply be a white dragon like all the
other corpses
brought back to life something like the
undead white horses the errors on the
other hand claimed that vision has been
turned into a dragon version of a white
Walker HBO vivid sky refer to a bazarian
as an ice dragon and said that he was
shooting blasts of freezing ice breath
out of its mouth instead of fire making
offense even more confused however due
to the season 7 finale being submitted
for an Emmy nomination the script was
made publicly available in August 2018
clarifying a few points but also raising
more questions and contradictions the
script directly refers to bazarian as a
nice try on the script gives description
when the night king appears at the end
that is done same thing to with Aryan
that he did to crecer Suns only those
were babies and this is a dragon it's
according to the TV writers through
zarin's now a dragon version of a by
Walker the script also specifies that
he's breathing blue colored fire not ice
blasts making HBO fever sky statement
false even though the script finally
confirmed to us that visions of I Walker
rather than a white it also raises
several issues the script says that the
net King's done the same thing to be
there and that he did to cress her son's
only those were babies and this is a
dragon this is not correct
the night king did not do the same thing
to Vizier he did to cress her son's eyes
area most clearly they then had to be
resurrected in contrast cress her son
explicitly needed to be delivered alive
to be turned into white walkers the
script her first vision is an ice dragon
but this is not for the nice dragon
heads an ice dragon is a legendary
creature somewhat resembling a dragon
but made out of living eyes this
mythological creatures of legend in the
world of Westeros breathe blasts of
freezing cold in contrast to how normal
dragons breathe out fire they're called
breath can instantly freeze people and
think solid a mirror opposite of how
breath of regular dragons burned him as
Aryan is not made out of living guys
he's a flesh-and-blood undead creature
he's bringing blue fire instead of cold
which is why vissarion is not a nice
dragon
long story short with Aryans not white
he's a white Walker and fire cannot kill
him Danish dragons cannot kill him his
urn can be killed by two things and two
things only dragon glass similar in
steel share dragon could rip out his
throat but what would that do to the end
a dragon vizier no longer needs to
breathe or blood to stay alive the only
thing that his dragons could do is to
dismember him so that he's unable to fly
and move so that someone could pierce
civilians still sword or dragon glass
dagger to resign
however that might not be as easy as it
sounds even though vissarion's the
smallest out of the three he may have
just become the strongest out of the
three after he was resurrected his
strength and power have been increased
Missouri has been turned into white
Walker meaning that his siblings
superior size and numbers may not be
enough to slow him down so how to kill
this area so call it easiest way would
be to kill the man who resurrected him
the knight King as seen in the previous
season when Jean killed a white Walker
with Longclaw killing of Eibach results
with the instant collapse of the
servants they erased na Roberts King
knight King would result with the final
death of its Aryan as well as with the
collapse of his entire army since he
created all the white walkers who then
created old White's let's put it this
way you kill the knight King all the
white walkers die and if all white
walkers die all the whites collapse as
well because they have been created by
either by Walker's or their leader since
going night king would end the long
night I don't see him dying before his
dragon the living might eventually
defeat the night king but it's highly
unlikely that this jagan will die this
way early Stan before the very bitter
end
next out of a very few possible ways to
kill Vissarion will be with Qyburn
scorpion in blue team battle the power
cable scorpion was shown of inflicting a
flesh wound on its target Jurgen took a
serious hit in the shoulder forcing him
to land carried Pierce's eye instead of
his shoulder it were punctured his brain
and jorgen would have died the sister
wife of Aegon the conquerer a nice
Targaryen luster dragon in precisely
this manner during the conflict with the
Dornish with Sharon could be killed at a
very lucky shot from scorpion bowl that
would pierce his eye and drive into his
brain but only the normal head of the
bolt is replaced with dragon glass or
Valyrian steel another way to kill
vissarion will be with a magical weapon
that has something to do with wheels in
the books it's hinted that the living
side might be able to use some sort of
magical weapon to kill the night king
dragon there's a possibility that the
living could use one more weapon to kill
this area just as the night King used
his magical weapon to kill a dragon the
living might use their own magical
weapon to kill the night king dragon in
the weapon in question are railroad
arrows this game comes from the events
that happened during Aegon's conquest
back then torn Stark the king who
kneeled that are witnessing most of the
kingdom's south of the next submitting
one by one to Aegon turn decided to
amass his army in march south to meet
Targaryen warlord on the battlefield
after singing of dragons and his massive
hosts I realized that the war was
already lost instead of fighting he
chose to bend a knee and surrender his
crown in order to save his people while
some of the northern Lords did agree
with this someone near him only to find
and die against the Targaryen sinner
dragons but it was thorns best her
brother Brandon's known that had another
idea
Brandon offered to cross the Trident
along at night to sneak into the
Targaryen camp and assassinate the
dragons during judge that this was
impossible and that the failed attempt
would
additional retaliation from targaryen so
he chose instead Sam Brannan and three
maesters across the river to negotiate a
gun and surrender how did his best
brother of the king who kneeled imagined
his heroic quest to succeed charging
into three dragons to the sword surely
would not do the job the hint comes from
brains vivid visions in the novels in a
dance with dragons brain stark has
several visions of the past through
Winterfell scar tree one of these
visions is of a pale fierce and dark
eyed young man who slices three branches
of the weirwood and shapes them into
arrows it has been theorized that this
may be Brandon Snow preparing arrows to
kill the three dragons of Aegon the
conquerer arrows from real roots were
already used to kill a dragon daemon
Blackfyre and Sons were also cut down by
shadow arrows fired from the root boughs
that the command of Lord Brien and
rivers the man who would later become
the three-eyed raven for some reason we
are apparently being told that vir roots
are able to slay dragons even though one
might say that those arrows would not
work on the knight Kings Dragon I think
it's just the opposite
it would work on this area injustice or
even better than dragon glass or
Valyrian steel given the origin of the
night King and White Walkers the White
Walkers are made by the children of the
forest who draw their powers from the
weirwoods some theorists believe that
the piece of that power could kill the
night Kings dragon with one shot for
this to come true brain will have to see
the same vision he's seen the books that
Oh Brendan Snow preparing very rude
arrows to kill dragons and figure out
that it is if it truly is one of the
very few possible ways to kill the night
Kings dragon I believe that if this
comes true brain will figure it out in
the heat of battle between the living
and the dead
there will be of the crucial points from
bran to share this information with the
most skilled archers among the ranks
having varied arrows made for the entire
army would be quite a job to do not to
mention that there are very few V routes
so who would we branched champion in
this task would Brenna point this
essential role to his sibling Johnson or
perhaps Serb Ronald Blackwater whose
skill has already been proven and shown
off multiple times the best choice to be
Theon Greyjoy accomplished Archer whose
confidence would surely be restored
after completing such a task of a huge
importance rule inside thean skill be
the longbow has been pointed out
multiple times and since he has done
nothing with it to this date he might
just use it in the final season perhaps
this has been foreshadowed back in the
first season
Ron di an island sigil mccracken its
words we do not say lords the Greyjoy's
veins for their skills at archery
navigation and lovemaking and failed
rebellions schedule a stag a crown in
conclusion among the very few possible
ways of killing the knocking Schrag when
I place my bet on Qyburn scorpion dragon
list or a leader in still pointed bolts
how I would like to Zairian to die would
be an epic battle between all three
dragons and their riders Danny riding
Jah gone along with Justin riding ray
got the drago named after his father
fighting a knight king and his dad that
dragged on to the bitter end
bazarian kills drug on Danny barely
survives with zero saloons Rago but
while Vizier and injured stray girl John
swings a leg over his saddle and leaps
from his dragon to the night Kings just
like Prince daemon targaryen did during
the dance of dragons well in Damon's
hand was dark sister House Targaryen
Valyrian steel swords John has his own
Valyrian steel sword Lanka well Prince
daemon fought his nephew Prince Aegon
Johnston will fight the night king it
will end exactly the same just like
Damon did Jen will also kill his
opponent but this time opponents Dragon
will not strike the lake it will
collapse all the dragons will die the
night king and his army will be defeated
and Justin will be severely injured but
he will thrive it's even rumored that
Damon survived the fall as well and
lived a quiet life out of sight with his
lover this would be my take on how I'd
like to see it happening based on no
evidence or hints to sported compared to
previous possible ways of killing his
area rather than some history and lore
that would repeat although it's
something george RR martin tends to do
and as always i hope you guys enjoyed
this video if you did please make sure
to subscribe to our Channel and I hope
to see you in the next one peace
[Music]